bienvenue à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de paris saclay
le mag au sommaire de cette édition une
visite guidée de l'exposition paris
saclay le futur en chantier avec un s à
chantier évidemment cette exposition se
tient ici même à la maison de
l'architecturé en ile de france une
exposition qui nous propose une
photographie un instantané de paris
saclay beaucoup de projets sont en cours
en chantier d'autres sont installés
depuis bien longtemps c'est le cas du
centre de recherche et de développement
de danone son directeur r&d plessis nous
a rencontrés nous reviendrons aussi sur
la première édition européenne de l'open
compute project cet événement a
rassemblé plus de 700 personnes à
l'école polytechnique notre équipe était
sur place autre temps fort en cette fin
d'année la première édition de smart
manufacturing paris saclay conférence
cet événement international s'est tenu
au palais des congrès à versailles plus
de 500 personnes y ont participé
elles ont réfléchi autour de la
thématique de l' usine du futur enfin
n'oublions pas notre agenda toutes les
informations de votre territoire en bref
et en images ce sera à la fin de ce
numéro
nous voici donc à paris à la maison de
l'architecturé c'est ici que paris
saclay se met en scène paris saclay le
futur en chantier une exposition qui se
veut un point d'étape un instantané de
votre territoire puisqu'il ya un projet
c'est un processus qui se dévoile ici
celui du plateau de saclay celui de sa
future université une fresque
monumentale nous a permis de nous faire
une idée plus précise visites guidées
tout de suite avec pierre weiss c'est le
président directeur général de
l'établissement public paris saclay
dès le départ il s'agissait par une
exposition grand public et parler du
projet urbain mais pas seulement sous
l'angle de l'architecturé l'urbanisme
mais aussi parler de la science
du paysage et de l'aspect économique
aussi aisé par on a cherché à voir
comment on va représenter ces
différentes disciplines avec des
supports architecturaux et comment le
rendre communicables est compréhensible
au grand public
comme toile de fond des trois journées
de tables rondes des conférences on a
proposé de faire une fresque qui en même
temps monumental et entend légère qui
représente aussi bien des avancées
scientifiques des personnes qui ont
contribué au projet comme
des lieux dont certains sont à venir ou
d'autres existants et même des éléments
naturels
la difficulté avec un tel projet
d'urbanisme c'est la très grande échelle
et donc on a choisi de montrer en
différentes échelles le projet
d'urbanisme les idées derrière mais
aussi les maquettes des premiers
bâtiments qui sont en cours de
développement
on montre plus un processus qu'un projet
finit donc par exemple il ya des
maquettes de concours qui sont des
versions la première des projets
architecturaux qui sont toutes exposées
en arrière chapelle et les matériaux
utilisés sont des matériaux de chantier
brut
dans notre équipe qui avec michel
desvigne paysagiste il ya un énormément
d'ingénieurs de différentes spécialités
d'experts de tous genres c'est vraiment
un projet transdisciplinaire et
collaboratif
on travaille sur le plan urbain depuis à
peu près cinq ans mais on est certain
que l'ensemble ça durera 15 ans et ce
sera une évolution dans le temps qui
n'arrête jamais
essakane on devient une réalité sur le
terrain on voit des grues qui
apparaissent un peu partout on voit des
chantiers qui se met en place le
transport en commun en site propre qui
est en train d'être réalisé on a pensé
que c'était utile et important de le
faire savoir à l'ensemble des
communautés intéressées par ce genre de
par ce projet et au grand public
l'idée c'est de montrer à la fois le
projet d'ensemble donc ça commence à
être impressionnant et dès l'année
prochaine les chantiers vont encore se
multiplier pour la mise en oeuvre
on quitte paris pour palaiseau s'est
jusqu'ici je vous emmène dans l'un des
nombreux centres de recherche et de
développement du territoire ce centre
c'est danone nous avons rencontré son
directeur hervé plessis il nous explique
pourquoi le groupe a choisi paris saclay
et il revient aussi sur ses recherches
scientifiques et technologiques qui sont
menés dans ce centre sur des produits
que nous consommons régulièrement
le centre de recherche daniel carasso
c'est un des centres de recherche
internationaux de danone et notre centre
est d'aider à la recherche en sciences
et en technologie pour les produits
laitiers frais et pour les eaux
minérales au service de l'ensemble du
groupe danone à travers le monde
ici on fait de la science dit à nos
produits parce que la mission de danone
c'est d'apporter la santé par
l'alimentation au plus grand nombre et
qui dit santé et alimentation du
travail scientifique pour prouver les
comprendre les effets de nos produits
alors on fait de la séance mais on fait
aussi de la technologie parce que nous
fabriquons ici
des yaourts on fabrique des boissons à
base d'eaux minérales et donc nous avons
une partie de nos équipes qui
travaillent sur les technologies qui
permettent de réaliser de fabriquer ce
type de produits nous hébergeons aussi
sur notre centre le développement pour
les produits laitiers et un certain
nombre de boissons pour les marques de
danone qui sont vendus en france donc
nous développons les huissiers des
produits que vous retrouver nombreux
supermarchés et vos magasins tout au
long de l'année
on s'est implanté ici d'abord parce que
danone souhaitait quand on est arrivé en
2002 regrouper plusieurs centres de
recherche qu'ils étaient en région
parisienne est donc ici sur le plateau
de saclay sa apparaissait comme un
endroit naturel pour se regrouper mais
aussi à cause de l'ensemble des
partenariats qu'on peut développer
autour de nous tout l'environnement tout
notre écosystème scientifique
extrêmement important lors il ya l'agro
paris tech et l'inra sont bien sûr des
partenaires naturels pour danone mais
nous travaillons aussi avec l'université
d'orsay on développe en commun un projet
autour d'une chaire alliés aux aliments
du futur et à la cuisine du futur nous
travaillons aussi avec des élèves de
polytechnique qu'on accueille ici pour
des stages
cet environnement scientifique et
économique c'est absolument clé pour une
r&d mondiale comme la nôtre qui
travaillent énormément en partenariat
c'est une grande première l'école
polytechnique a accueilli la première
édition européenne de l'open compute
project un événement lancé en 2011 par
facebook une première française piloté
par la société sds une pme spécialisée
dans la conception d'ordinateurs à forte
efficacité énergétique et c'est tout
l'enjeu de cette manifestation inciter
la france à développer de nouvelles
technologies tout de suite les
explications de jean marie verdun le
créateur de la ds
bienvenue aux premiers semis open
compute européen
le projet open compute est un projet qui
est collaboratif a été lancée en 2011
par facebook avec pour objectif
d'améliorer l'efficacité énergétique des
grands ensembles de données
informatiques qui stocke aujourd'hui vos
données personnelles est qui qui d'oise
les garder dans un endroit sécurisé et
d'une manière efficace
l'événement a été un co organisé avec la
fondation open poursuites aux états unis
qui perd notre société suite il des
stocks système ce qui est présente sur
le plateau de saclay depuis le mois de
novembre 2006 qui développe des
ordinateurs sur sur ce plateau et je
suis moi même un ancien étudiant du
plateau de saclay et donc il nous a
semblé naturel d'essayer d'ancrer cette
communauté autour du futur campus de
l'université paris 5 m
on a accueilli plus de 700 personnes
durant cet événement il fallait qu'on
puisse tous se réunir dans une salle
pour pouvoir échanger et donc l'école
polytechnique était la seule école a
disposé de ses moyens logistiques pour
pouvoir accueillir ce type d'événement
traditionnellement projet open compute
était un projet orienté vers
l'international c'est un projet
communautaire qui traite d'une
problématique
assez spécifique du développement
d'équipements matériels donc
traditionnellement en france plutôt
orienté logiciel de développement
matériel la zone us et la zone asie sont
sont plus dynamique autour de autour de
cette thématique la france aujourd'hui
est fortement consommatrice de ces
technologies les développent très peu et
l'idée c'est d'essayer justement de
d'améliorer ce point et de faire émerger
soit des nouvelles start-up souhaite
sensibiliser une partie de l'écosystème
informatique autour de autour de ces
thématiques et pouvoir développer de
nouvelles technologies apportées nous
mêmes notre pierre à l'édifice
la communauté open compute est
totalement ouverte donc elle est ouverte
aux étudiants ou retraités aux
professionnels à toute personne qui
souhaite s'investir dans cette
communauté est donc naturellement on a
retrouvé un public d'étudiants puisqu'on
est sur un campus universitaire mais
aussi d'un public de professionnels avec
du networking de haut niveau
autre événement phare en cette fin
d'année le smart manufacturing paris sa
clique conférence le leader de
l'automobile de l'énergie de
l'aéronautique de la sécurité et de la
ville intelligente se sont retrouvés au
palais des congrès à versailles
cette conférence inédite a réuni plus de
500 personnes autour de la thématique de
lusine futur paris saclay le mag a suivi
pour vous cette journée de rencontre et
pour l'un des organisateurs christian
bale il ya urgence il faut sensibiliser
les pme écoutez le
cet événement smps 2014 le premier on
veut se lancer dans un cycle annuel et
notre but principal c'est de fédérer
tous les acteurs autour de la thématique
du futur acteur ce qu'ils soient grands
groupes industriels
pme et laboratoires de recherches et
école de formation aussi donc l'occasion
de rassembler cette immense et de
conférences ou sur la scène on explique
les grands enjeux de la thématique est
dans la salle ce qu'on veut c'est qu'il
ya plus en plus d'acteurs surtout les
pme qui se sentent concernés par la
thématique pour pouvoir apporter leur
leurs briques technologiques
la contribution les écoles bien
comprendre les enjeux de la formation et
pour les chercheurs bien comprendre les
besoins d'industrie pour pouvoir
orienter aussi leurs fins de recherche
la thématique du futur est connu depuis
quelques quelques années déjà au niveau
de l'europe il ya vraiment une
association européenne de recherche sur
la thématique pour ça existe depuis 2009
la france est un peu présente donc la
france doit doit être plus présente dans
cette association le gouvernement a
lancé le plan nouvelle trois industriels
le point numéro 34 s'appelle usine du
futur donc là on est bien on est on est
bien dans la thématique on est bien
concerné
ou est à faire c'est les années à venir
qu'ils ont montrée justement l'intérêt
porté par les acteurs et le nombre
d'acteurs soit tout ça qu'on veut voir
ces noms d'acteurs parce que aujourd'hui
il ya quelques champions avec quelques
entreprises on gagne combien compris
encore faut-il en mener d'autres
industriels d'autres pme pour pouvoir
travailler ensemble
le plateau de saclay giresse et
l'opportunité mais irremplaçable pas ce
que sont leurs territoires pour
l'instant on va arriver à rassembler les
besoins des écoles donc la formation on
rassemble déjà des griefs de recherche
le seven un bon exemple et puis aussi on
a des grands entreprises qui sont bien
installés 104,5 les docks tous les
grands acteurs sont déjà là
c'est un terreau pour dire c'est plus
qu'un territoire c'est un terreau de
synergies ou les gens pouvoir travailler
ensemble parce qu'ils sont proches
avant de nous quitter à rapide coup
d'oeil sur l'agenda du mois avec déjà le
coup d'envoi des travaux du nouveau
bâtiment de l'école nationale de la
statistique et de l'administration
économique
les futurs 875 étudiants et les 340
enseignants-chercheurs de l'enesad
pourront bientôt profiter de leurs deux
nouveaux amphithéâtres et de la future
cafétéria et de son patio végétalisé
ce bâtiment imaginé par l' agence cap
sera livré en septembre 2016 à palaiseau
dans le quartier de l'école
polytechnique
enfin n'oubliez pas vous avez jusqu'au
20 décembre pour découvrir cette
exposition paris saclay le futur en
chantier ne photographie en temps réel
de ce lieu qui va accueillir la plus
grande université de france et c'est à
voir à la maison de l'architecturé en
ile-de-france paris saclay le mag c'est
déjà fini au nom de toute l'équipe je
vous souhaite d'excellentes fêtes de fin
d'année on se retrouve très vite pour un
prochain numéro
d'ici là toutes les informations sont
sur notre site pps point fr